Welcome to "Google Developers
Weekly" for October 7, 2013.
I'm Louis Gray, and this is our
highlight reel of what's
happening in the world
of Google Developers,
on the set and off.
As you know, social is a key
ingredient in today's
applications.
Getting social network
integration just right can
delight your users, but getting
it wrong could get a
big mistake.
Nazmul Idris and Don Dodge get
social and tell us just how to
strike the right balance.
Mano Marks put his location
marker in Mountain View and
taught us how to get started
with the Google
Maps SDK for iOS.
This quick tutorial guides
you on how to set up your
development environment, test
an API key, and create that
first application.
From Milan, Google Developer
expert Mauro Solcia explained
how to create your first app
that displays information from
files stored in Google Drive and
display them on a web page
using JavaScript.
Back in Mountain View, Josh
Livni and Felipe Hoffa gave us
a glimpse into the future of
air travel using Google
BigQuery and the Google Maps
JavaScript API visualizing
correlations.
And traveling to a place that
knows quite a bit about
clouds, not to mention rain, we
find ourselves at the first
event taped in our new
Seattle studio.
Brian Dorsey provided us with a
quick introduction to Google
Compute Engine load balancing.
Watch for many more clouds
in this space.
From Tel Aviv, Ido Green showed
us the power of the
Google Eclipse plug-in and how
you can push your code to App
Engine with only two clicks.
And as we like to say,
live from New York.
Ikai Lan debuted the new home
of YouTube API samples on
GitHub at GitHub.com/YouTube.
The event walks through why we
made the move, our project
setup, and shows basic commands
and GUI tools to get
you up and running.
From Buenos Aires, Nick
Bortolotti and his dog return
with "GDL LatAm" talking
App Engine.
Watch Nick's talk and learn
about how the Focus Ninja can
make your projects better.
Closing out the week in our
studios in Mountain View, we
hosted the MEAN stack
of MongoDB,
Express, Node.JS and AngularJS.
Google Engineering Director
Brad Green connected with
leaders from MongoDB, Breeze.js,
and StrongLoop to
talk about making managing data
simpler, even in mobile
enterprise environments.
And it wouldn't be a full report
if I didn't highlight
the fantastic work being done
by our teammates in Android
Developers Live.
This week saw a new "Android
Design in Action," a new
"GameOn!" episode with Todd
Kerpleman, and a trio of
DevBites aimed at improving
your applications
through best practices.
Check out all their videos
at Developers.Googl
e.com/Live/Android.
And news flash--
not everybody in the world
speaks English.
Because of that, Google recently
worked with Udacity
to translate many of its web
application MOOCs into Spanish
and Brazilian Portuguese.
Captioned versions of several
videos are now available.
[SPANISH].
And this week we launched a
Google+ community for Cloud
Platform developers.
We're looking for comments,
videos, questions and all
other kinds of content
in the new community.
And what better place than the
cloud for a community about
developing in the cloud?
For those of you building
sharing into your iOS
applications, we just enabled
you to upgrade the Google+
sharing experience
inside your apps.
The Google+ iOS SDK now enables
you to use a native
share box including image
and video attachments.
Best of all, this only requires
you to change a
single line of source code.
See the new Google+ iOS SDK for
this and other updates.
And when it comes to memory
leaks, you hate them, we hate
them, your users hate them.
In our mutual never-ending quest
for future memory leaks,
we've released a new doc on
memory profiling for your
JavaScript apps.
Read a little, and save
your own memory.
And we were really in a
documenting mood this week.
Over on the Google Maps
JavaScript API, we launched
new documents that show
you how to add
overlays to your maps.
Check out the docs and sample
code to see how to put shapes,
markers and info windows
on the map.
And to make sure that you never
miss a thing from the
world of Google Developers,
subscribe to Google Developers
on YouTube.
And check out the GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray, and I'll see
you back in the studio.